and then when they get to 70 that's
where the big problems start because the
French haven't invented a word for 70
I always assume the one thing that is
kind of international is numbers
mathematics that's the one thing that is
the same everywhere you're about to ruin
this at you yes I am one thing that that
you learn when you're studying a foreign
language is that counting systems are
very different and in fact it's one of
the ways that you can tell if somebody's
a really good speaker of a foreign
language you can really tell what their
real mother tongue is when they start
counting
because even if somebody operates you
know an English person living in France
when they start counting to themselves
that probably count to themselves in
English they're our closest neighbors so
you'd have thought that maybe they count
in the same way as us but one of the
things that I have to keep repeating to
my students is that in fact the French
don't count in the same way and they use
numbers in very different ways in a
whole range of different everyday
environments let me give you some
examples so the French well what are we
doing England when we're counting
numbers we give numbers the first 12
numbers when we're counting we give them
individual names so we go 1 to 12 and
then we slip into a thing where we go 13
14 which is kind of 3 and 10 4 and 10
and so forth the French start off in a
slightly different way they go a bit
further I'll boot work at some key set
enough disposed dues tires guitars gas
says and then they go for a 17 so deset
10 7 de suite 10 eight is enough 10 9
and then vamped for 20 it's very similar
the counting system after that to
English so they go on to 20 I just said
with var then they go to 30 Tom cow
haunt for 40 sancorp for 50 swamp for 60
and then when they get to 70 that's
where the big problems start because the
French haven't invented a word for 70
instead what they do is they count to 60
and add 10 so whereas we go to 60 and
then go to 70 a French person goes to 60
but then goes to 60 plus 10 because they
say swass oldest fossil Dees is 70 in
French so solid is literally means 60 10
but it means 70 oh they know what the
number 70 is they don't they don't sort
of do this plus business they and a
French person when they hear you say
sauce on these they don't think
that's 60 and 10 they see 70 so the
mental picture that is conjured by the
Sounders Wasel this is still 70 the same
as we we word and then they continue by
instead of say they haven't invented a
word for example for 71 so that's SWA
salt eons literally 60 and 11 it's
rather odd with these ones that they say
SWA sont a alls is the word for hand
because when they get to 72 they just
say SWA sont doozer okay swass on
Toulouse sixty twelve and it's only when
we're dealing with ones that they use
the a but it gets even more confusing
from the English point of view because
you think okay so we've got 60 ten that
70 Plus on tails source on goose what's
on place what's not get those for some
girls so I son says so solid he said
sauce on these meat sauce on these nerve
what do they do when they get to 80
surely they got a word for 80 well no
because the French when they get to that
number
they say cat revoir which means four 20s
well that's what it means for 20
literally the French of course when they
hear cat kata see 80 in their minds and
then they go cat over a four twenties
one four twenties to not for wadies and
man no they just be are the reason they
don't say four twenties and one is
because it's too many words so there's
also a style issue here because you know
the French sure love their style but
what they do do then and this is the
other weird thing when they get to 90
they still haven't even thought of
another word for 90 or a decent word for
90 so what do they say they say a
profound these four twenties ten and
then when they get to 91
they say cat over walls for 20s 1192 is
Kappa Van Duzer 93 is kaki avancez 94 is
Calcavecchia doors 95 kept Laveau Gaz
and so it goes until they get up to a
hundred and they have invented a word
for hundred so 100 is song one of the
big problems of course with this kind of
numbering system is when you're
listening to somebody giving you a phone
number because if I could just explain
let me let me think of an English
phone number so you might have you have
oh one one five so that's your
Nottingham code then you have nine six
two would be the sub code for the
exchange and then the individual number
would be five seven eight two and in
English we would read out all of the
numbers oh one one five we might say oh
double one five nine six two five seven
eight - this isn't a real number by the
way no no I'll just make that way okay
so that's your that's your an example of
an English telephone number but in
France they do it completely differently
they would save the numbers and they
will say they will actually distinguish
the numbers 62 58
49 27 and when you ask somebody for
their phone number they will tell you
that it is 62 58 4927 they won't say
they'll do that for all telephone
numbers they won't say six two five
eight four nine to seven and this causes
not big problems but if you're on the
telephone to a client in France who
wants your mobile number and you're used
to giving your mobile number in the ink
in the way the English do and then you
try to do it into the French they find
that very difficult to cope with and it
works in the other direction my students
are endlessly telling me about the
problems they had copying down telephone
numbers and of course the really big
problems start when you get to numbers
and start with a 6 with a 7 with an 8
and with a 9 well it's a problem because
if you're English and you hear swass on
let's remember that numbers that what we
would call 60 to 69 start with a words
font but soda numbers 70 to 79 let's say
that your friend starts saying my number
is a same French monomer or ce soir
thought you start you do that and then
they say a all's you have to go back and
correct it because it's not swamped at
all it's 71 but the other thing that the
French do with numbers while we're on
the subject that's the French for ten
point six nine let's say that that's the
world record for the women's hundred
meters - in the Olympics okay you can
see that's very different from the way
that we would we would write it in
English it's also very different from
the
we would say it there we've got a
decimal point and the French are using a
comma but they also say it differently
in English we say ten point six nine
because we separate the tents and the
hundredths okay but the French would say
ten comma 69 okay so you have to listen
out very carefully if you're watching a
French sports commentary for example
you're watching the Olympic Games in
France and you're trying to catch the
time you have to listen out for not ten
point six nine but this dog yudice
wasn't enough ten comma 69 so once again
you've got this issue of numbers being
grouped together and that's something
the French do all the time they don't
separate individual numbers out they
group them and give them and use their
name yeah the word the French use for a
comma is a value land they use that in
grammar as they use it in numbers as
well so when a French person reads out
this time then they will say this Doug
you comma SWAT op nerf to a French
person is that ten point six nine five
or is that ten thousand six hundred
ninety five it's ten they are gue 695 so
it would be this vo you'll see some
Catalan cones that would be the way they
express it
how would a French person write 10,600
mattifier well 10 they would either just
do that and very often they leave a
space in a French textbook you might
find that there's a space between the 10
between the thousands and the 695 or
occasionally this is going to confuse
you just occasionally they'll do that
10,000 . 6 9 5 so in fact you could say
that the French in the English do
exactly the opposite thing and you could
argue that it's just to confuse each
other and it's deliberate well I don't
have a problem with it but it has caused
problems in the past there was a case of
rather unfortunate case in a French
hospital a few years ago where there was
a serious a too large a dose of
something was administered to patients
simply because of a Mis reading of a
decimal point for this or a comma not
being read the right way round so it can
be a big problem in technical
translation technical translators need
to be absolutely sure that they get it
right because otherwise it can go very
very wrong
if you'd like to hear a bit more about
French numbers including why it's
impossible to score 20 out of 20 in
France check out another video we've got
here on numberphile or if you just like
to hear more about languages in general
from people like Paul and others check
out another channel I've got called
words of the world it's got all sorts of
fascinating videos about things like
California or biscuit or vodka there's
loads of videos on there already and
there's new ones going on every week so
maybe subscribe